hey we are going to play we said it
Justin Bieber or Angelica pickles it is
a very simple game I will be reading
contestants quotes and they will have to
decide if fact what was said by Justin
Bieber a 20 year old pop star from
Canada or Angelica pickles the three
year old rat from Rugrats sounds easy
right I don't have to listen to anything
you have to say Justin Bieber Angelica
pickles Angelica that is encourage us in
Bieber said this at his deposition I
don't like you
Angelica that is incorrect Justin Bieber
said this while holding up traffic in
2012 give me one good reason why I
should do what you say
look at him sign that paper again that
is incorrect that was Angelica she
yelled it at Lil when Lil was pretending
to be Angelica no parents no rules and
no one can stop me
Bieber pickles pickles that is incorrect
Bieber said this while discussing his
ideal world wow yeah
a vacation is when you get to do exactly
what you want all the time Justin Bieber
that is incorrect Angelica said that in
the two-part episode a Rugrats vacation
look I get what you're doing but nobody
talks to me like that Justin Bieber and
is incorrect Angelica pickles in this
any 3rd season premiere of Rugrats
sometimes I wish I could be you just so
I could be friends with me
Bieber that is incorrect again jelica
I'm special and let's face it I'm
definitely talented
Justin Bieber that is incorrect Angelica
said that in the episode piece of cake
while she was daydreaming about entering
a talent show Wow mom is awful at
cooking
she is just awful awful awful Justin
Bieber Angelica pickles what do you guys
say hello Angelica pickles I'm sorry
that was said by Justin Bieber my radio
morning internship when I want to get
something I just have to ask my mom
Angelia that is incorrect Justin Bieber
said this on Oprah in 2010 this is
school yeah I will [ __ ] beat the [ __ ]
out of you Oh Justin that is correct
that was Justin Bieber